le pido su análisis sobre el comentario
del embajador cree que se trata de una
salida de tono personal o refleja el
pensamiento del partido comunista a
pesar de que las autoridades de Beijing
lo hayan rectificado
Muchas gracias este Rosa bueno respecto
a esta declaración hay que rescatar
algunos aspectos importantes no en
primer momento señalar que este pues
bueno este embajador el embajador look
ha sido como de estos nuevas tácticas
diplomáticas que se han utilizado en
China en los últimos años he conocidos
Como los Guerrero lobo no en los cuales
de alguna forma han comenzado a tener un
mayor protagonismo en el ejercicio de la
diplomacia y las posturas que se tienen
a nivel internacional en las cuales en
específico con lo que se declaró el
viernes pasado de alguna manera
revisando la la entrevista por completo
pareciera ser que hay un momento en el
cual el embajador look quiere hacer como
de manera muy cautelosa el hacer
declaraciones para que no se comience a
generar esta comparación entre lo que es
Ucrania y lo que es el tema Taiwán que
también se trató dentro de esta
entrevista en la cual pues al final del
día termina como una total este
declaración desafortunada por parte del
embajador Lu que de alguna manera pues
bueno es algo que sorprende yo creo que
no solamente a la opinión pública sino
también al propio Ministerio de de
relaciones exteriores china por ello Es
que de alguna manera Sale este la vocera
Mao a deslindarse totalmente de de estas
declaraciones no en las cuales pues
obviamente esto pone a a generar otro
tipo de estrategias por parte del
ministerio hacia todo lo que son los
países principalmente bálticos y sobre
todo la encrucijada en la que le pone en
este papel en el cual se había digamos
Auto propuesto China con respecto a la
mediación de la paz en Ucrania
claro precisamente Hablando ahora de las
consecuencias para china no y es que los
países bálticos y Francia han llamado a
Los embajadores chinos en sus
territorios a consultas y al jefe de la
diplomacia de la Unión Europea josep
borrell ha calificado el comentario de
inaceptable pero se espera que este
episodio tenga alguna consecuencia
digamos real en las relaciones entre la
Unión Europea y China
bueno Considero que de alguna forma si
viene a volver complejo el escenario hay
que recordar que venimos a principios de
mes de esta gira que va a ser Emanuel
macron Y en este caso este la presidenta
de la comisión europea Wonder Legend en
el cual de alguna forma se parecía que
se construye una especie de diálogo
positivo para China y Que obviamente
este tipo de declaraciones va a a
generar esta digamos pausa en en la
vinculación entre China con la Unión
Europea Considero que de alguna forma lo
que podemos esperar en próximos días es
pues una serie de notas diplomáticas de
de alguna forma este estos llamados no
hacia los distintos Embajadores de los
países involucrados en esta en estas
declaraciones insistor principalmente
estos países bálticos que son los que ya
han reaccionado a de alguna forma ver si
hay un se puede tocar como una
declaración oficial o no entonces creo
que ese es el punto a esperar